hey everybody welcome to the great big
story YouTube channel I'm Dave I'm
Jillian welcome to the show
today's show is about people building
things we've got castles we've got
houses we even have trucks we were
floating island and our first story
we're going to head up north to Alaska
and there is a man who is building his
poem to the sky
whoo like that let's watch the story
a lot of people call this the dr. Seuss
house here so well nobody asked dr.
Seuss for permission to do that they
refer to that because of some of the
ideas of dr. Seuss ooh I think it was a
genius I think a lot of good for the
world I try and write poetry and I kind
of think of this as a poem to the sky
I am Philip Paul Widener my owner and
builder Goose Creek Tower because I went
to MIT and I'm kind of a frustrated
architects I like building I just
designed it out of my head we didn't
have blueprints we drew it out on
cardboard plywood just as we were going
what I'm going to end up doing
eventually put some hooks here hang pots
and pans off of this in the kitchen I
started to build a 40 by 40 scribe blog
cabin I realized I could put pillars on
top and put another house on top of us
and I just kept going we got the 185
feet and stopped because 200 feet is
federal airspace now I just have to
finish it this is pretty much the less
ill stairs there are multiple levels in
there and I've tried to count them and
it's just impossible it depends how you
count stories I wanted to be able to see
and that's the reason I want up you can
actually see for at least 300 miles and
of course the Northern Lights around you
can really see I hope the Reese Creek
Tower will inspire other people to do
worthwhile things
now just in building but whatever they
do with their lives and every time I go
up there it's a different experience
kind of give you a sense of the enormity
of the universe so we're going to keep
it going we're going to head down the
coast of North America and meet a very
awesome couple Kathryn and Wayne built
not only a house but a floating island
on which the house is sitting I love it
and I especially love the dance floor
let's watch the store
[Music]
what do you say to people who just think
this is not a normal way of thank you
very much
[Music]
I'm Catherine and this is my husband
Wayne
I'm Ryan welcome to freedom coach
[Music]
we live in a secluded Cove the only
options we have to get here is by water
there are no road accesses the water is
our highway everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored we have our main living
house we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building for green houses
as I started to grow the garden and make
it larger than we had to have more space
for that garden everything is done with
a handsaw and hammer no power tools I
know every board and nail by name it's
about 500 tons a million pounds and I'm
Chloe I've been building tree fort since
number seven and I said well dad I'm
putting the tree fort in the ocean no
when I go down I got Lansing mm-hmm the
thing about living in Clark would sound
on the west coast of Vancouver Island
it's the richest biomass owner so the
opportunity to fish for dinner is stick
and I just can get in my canoe and
paddle out in ten minutes I can catch a
fish but when it's windy into too rough
out there I can land the coach
appreciated the house I was hoping to
make a lot more money as artists
so subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own it was a great
opportunity to actually move away from
the city to see if we could prosper up
here now 24 years later we're still
doing it
I can't imagine living any other way I
feel completely fulfilled for our next
story we're going to be hitting the road
in Japan and we're going to meet some
truck drivers and they're truly crazy
drugs they're basically like dance
parties on wheels like transformers kind
of they were maybe a little moving
carnivals yeah exactly
let's check out the story cool
taco do new canal Gong light it could go
bad in a half there are kimochi no
noggin or needle none day
[Music]
ESMA use to monitor the gutro - you are
the moon or Sun diagram Los Angeles
Boonen can ha get a choreographer to the
Gujarati no Amita Tory who you the Guru
is impressed everybody coalition traffic
in Kanata moon ago who used a garage
motor navazio named ray my garage much
on the schedule even though each cat
Atoka you know who visit a toga you will
know conducts toga
so in monroe no city isolated human over
emilio grandeur angle 800 multimers kono
decoder on Oh Jane gonna do tomorrow
kitey kitey awesomest a body they cried
a ni frock-coats Kristine Oller or that
you know if you vomit and then namaha
yellowish color
banku MOA Yui multitude of my dear
please give them record amigo
semantically we know jnana presented in
e GT this is a drama
so now my god cutesy Mercedes who rocked
a guinea a lot he came on kiona in
Arabic Arabic oh boy Kirilenko theta has
to be a quadrilateral 0.03 Yokoso akuto
or quiet emails was a you are in this
Cato CUDA Buddha Amitabha Conda Hawaii
roto Hawaii from committee running a
ling and holding a tatarin de SOI guitar
Nagi devoted Oeste Cousteau Moira condo
moral to Sochi motiva moti Morimoto
regatta in Kanata mention the boon
Connie no Guzman Italian a nice job of
Jillian a nice hammer Dave these
actually lead us into our next story
which is about building a castle by hand
so they're going to need a lot of you
enemies let's watch a get no signal
joseph earl campbell affordable union
[Music]
the pin button the nail maybe she did
Lucas please come home I shall forces
insects
no presentation fast India fabulous
person very Jamaica Street do download
man controller on dosa - dietra Zhen
sect donk laponia PLA Danny equivocal
Wakana premise no Sonny Chiba Fonda
person dough in contain key Batista
twofer Shauna not even [ __ ] a Quebec
City keep janitor possibly lively proof
to surrealism I organize different
associate occasional non-sovereign
facility fabric of a Union Jack la
víctima unite us on the devil I detected
unit although Jeff indeed and an
additional GM to cut a small hole now
compare I get long live exclusive a lot
addition to pasture get no attention
take a unique effects Iglesias security
symposium Bianca Tahoe to dalla sua
sponte resolved sacred kit10 a success
Du Bois is a betrayal AMA Acharya Lama
Tashi a Lama Veronica's fabulous insane
magnifique a doe claim energy an
acquired couscous Cobra 1200 una novia
to opposition Aquila Mahalo ke normal
common trippy others confess economic
dialogue
[Music]
thanks everybody for joining us and
watching these four great big stories
click the horse to subscribe and comment
below let us know what you think see you
next time Cheers